my breath carlin's ability to be able to
follow through with a
an intellectual idea set it up make you
see it and then get a laugh off of it
jim carrey to be able to physically show
you something so
so powerful and so in-depth and so
specific
that you laugh chris
chris rock being able to take something
political and being able to
be able to put such a shine on it
that it is hilarious and true
you know roseanne
just funny about who she is
who she is as a person okay
he's watching all these things charlie
fleischer was the voice
roger rabbit who's a brilliant comedian
when i watched his show and i would
watch him perform you want to go back
and read a book
he can take anything and make it comedy
metamorphosis
you know japanese shogun era
who does that so i was able to
to reign in all of them and then express
myself